fara
plus à sa façon de nous appeler ses
gosses on voyez bien qu'elle nous aimait
beaucoup cétait chez elle que notre
argent de poche disparaissait dans les
machines à
sous après les cours on allait boire un
verre quand on entrait Laurette
souriait et d'un seul coup nos leçons
nos
problèmes disparaissaient quand quand
elle nous
embrassait c'était bien chez
Laurette quand on faisait la fêtei
elle venait vers
nous
Laurette c'était
bien c'était
chouette quand on était fauché
[Musique]
elle payait pour
nous
Laurette
et plus encore afin qu'on soit
tranquille dans son café il y avait un
coin pour nous on s'y mettait pour voir
passer les filles et j'en connais qu'
plaisaient
beaucoup si par hasard on avait l'âme en
peine Laurette seule savait nous
consoler
elle nous parlait et on riait quand même
en un clin d'œil elle pouvait tout
changer
c'était bien chez
Laurette on y
retournera pour ne pas
l'oublier
Laurette ce sera bien ce sera
chouette et on
reparlera des histoires du
passé chez
Laurette ce sera
ce sera
chouette et on REP
parlera des histoire du
passé chez
Laurette